Are we ready?
As a stand-up comedian,
and a female,
it is very difficult
to get a little shine.
These are my comics.
You’re gonna love ‘em, because...
They ready!
I started doing stand-up comedy
while I was homeless.
I was my grandmother’s translator
my whole life.
I did not know how
to say syphilis in Spanish.
I started stand-up in 2003.
I was doing open mics.
I fell in love.
It was a outlet for me.
These dudes are being
disrespectful to my girl,
and she looking at me like,
“You just gonna let them talk
to me like that?”
I’m like, “Now hold on, baby.
I just play a man, all right?”
I grew up in a foster home.
Instead of crying about it,
I said, let me just put
this all on stage.
When it’s time
to get on the plane,
we need you to get to your
seat and sit the fuck down.
White people always wait to get
to they seat to fold they coat,
take out they laptop.
Look here, Bob.
Sit the fuck down!
I’ve been doing comedy
for 17 years.
There’s no reason
to be a lady comic
if you had a normal upbringing.
We were so poor, my dad bought
all of his medicine at pet stores
and insisted
it was the same thing.
Tiffany saw me.
She heard through my stories and
through my jokes on stage;
she knew that there was
somebody up under all of that.
I’m in the bathroom
changing tonight.
Two sisters in the bathroom,
“Girl, did you see the man
in the blue dress?”
And I said,
“Yeah, bitch, I’m in here.”
I can’t thank you enough, really.
-You don’t gotta thank me.
-All I gotta do...
is just go out there
and just kill it.
Yeah, that’ll be my thank you.
I joined Weight Watchers.
I did it 'cause Oprah told me to.
I woke up one morning,
Oprah Winfrey was on my screen,
and she said, “I love bread.
I love bread!”
The world deserves
to get to see y’all shine.
It’s time to shine.
Yeah!
Accept who you are.
I love you guys.
You all deserve to be treated
with the most respect.
Aw, bitch,
don’t you start that cryin’.
Well, what the hell wrong
with y’all?
Marlo, I seen you cry,
stop acting like you don’t cry.